تسمع عنها وقليلا ما تراها فماذا حققت
هدنه الروس يجيبك سريعا تواصل القتال في
محاور عده بشرق اوكرانيا
خاص في مناطق لوجان
في مدينه سوليدار في دنيا
الاستراتيجيه تحت سيطره قواتها
لا يكتبه الاوكرانيون كثيرا لهدنه الروس
المعلنه من طرف واحد لكنهم يسجلون ما
يرونها خروقات القوات المواليه لموسكو
[موسيقى]
من جديد لم يخفي القاده الموالون لروسيا
عدم التزامهم باي هدنه بل اعلن بعضهم هذا
الامر صراحه لم يتغير اي شيء لقد استمر
القصف على مواقعنا واستمرت محاولات التقدم
والهجوم من قبل القوات المعاديه هوبا
فيفا اتهام معاكس يشير الجيش الروسي الى
ان القوات الاوكرانيه واصلت قصف تجمعات
السكنيه الى جانب مواقعه في دون باس ومع
ان الروس يعددون بعض انجازاتهم في القتال
كاساذهم مثلا مسيره في القرن كما يقولون
فانهم يجددون التزامهم بهدله الساعات
السته والثلاثين
في اوكرانيا منذ منتصف السادس من يناير
وصل النظام كيف قصف التجمعات السكنيه
ومواقع جيشنا قمنا بالرد ودمرنا جميع
اطلاق النار الاخرانيه
يوجعني اذا صح الالتزام الروسي بوقف احادي
لاطلاق النار في عموم اوكرانيا فانه الاول
من نوعه منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا في
فبراير من العام الماضي ما زالت كيف
وحلفائها الغربيون يشككون في الدوافع
الحقيقيه لخطوه الرئيس الروسي تلك
ان الغايه من الهدنه هي سماح للمسيحيين
الارثوذكس بالاحتفال بعيد الميلاد وحضور
قداس العيد لكن الولايات المتحده تعتبرت
القرار الروسي مثيرا للسخريه
وقرا فيه الاتحاد الاوروبي محاوله لكسب
الوقت واعاده تجميع القوات الروسيه وحده
هذا رجل يدرك ماراميه قراره واحده
في قداس منتصف الليل بكاتدرائيه صممت في
الاساس للقاصرات الروس